70 years after the founding of the
United Nations it is worth reflecting on
what together the members of this body
have helped to achieve out of the ashes
of the Second World War having witnessed
the unthinkable power of the Atomic Age
the United States has worked with many
nations in this assembly to prevent a
third world war by forging alliances
with all the adversaries by supporting
the steady emergence of strong
democracies accountable to their people
instead of any foreign power and by
building an international system that
imposes a cost on those who choose
conflict over cooperation an order that
recognizes the dignity than equal worth
of all people that is the work of seven
decades that is the ideal that this body
at its best has pursued of course there
have been too many times when
collectively we have fallen short of
these ideals over seven decades terrible
conflicts have claimed untold victims
but we have pressed forward
slowly steadily to make a system of
international rules and norms that are
being better and stronger and more
consistent it is this international
order that is unwritten underwritten
unparalleled advances in human liberty
and prosperity it is this collective
endeavor that's brought about diplomatic
cooperation between the world's major
powers and buttress the global economy
that is lifted more than a billion
people from poverty it is these
international principles that have
helped constrain bigger countries from
imposing our will on smaller ones and
advance the emergence of democracy and
development and individual liberty on
every continent this progress is real it
can be documented in live saved and
agreements forged in diseases conquered
and in mouths fed and yet we come
together today knowing that the march of
human progress never travels in a
straight line that our work is far from
complete that dangerous currents risk
pulling us back into a darker more
disordered world today we see the
collapse of strongmen and fragile states
breeding conflict then driving innocent
men women and children across borders on
an epic scale brutal networks of Terror
have stepped into the backyard
technologies that empower individuals
are now also exploited by those who
spread disinformation or suppress
dissent or radicalize our youth global
capital flows of powered growth and
investment but also increased risk of
contagion weakened the bargaining power
of workers and accelerated inequality